oh
my goodness a delicious fish i love
eating oh that is a pile of seafood
[Music]
all right luke here at the outdoor boys
youtube channel and today we're going on
a fishing crabbing date night and my
brother and his wife are coming along
it's a double date and uh we're gonna go
catch king salmon and tanner crabs and
cook them up and eat them
we're gonna drive about four hours south
the homer and get a little room for the
night uh my oldest sister is watching
our children so hopefully she'll be
alive and healthy thank you michelle and
andrew
so brave
so brave
oh
welcome to homer we're on the end of the
homer spit at the lands in hotel
we're gonna check in for the night so
we'll be nice and ready for an early
charter in the morning
and we'll see you guys in the morning
because we've got a fishing charter see
you then
[Music]
oh
well good morning you guys sleep well
yeah i'll tell you my favorite thing in
the world about winter fishing charters
is they don't leave the dock until like
nine o'clock so we can actually have
breakfast and sit down and eat breakfast
right now the weather is really iffy
noah says there's seven to eight foot
waves out in the ocean right now which
is
it's aggressive
how you doing i'm josh hi i'm back
all right guys we're here with josh with
big butt charters and uh we're going for
winter kings
and yes the name of the charter is big
but i mean
gross
oh now unfortunately the weather's a
little a little bit nasty i heard seven
to eight foot waves out in the open but
uh but the weather is kind of limiting
our fishing spot so we're gonna try to
make the best lemonade we can out of
these lemons but uh nothing else we're
gonna go fishing in the middle of the
winter right yeah we'll give it a shot
if you guys want to try this i'm gonna
go ahead and put a link down in the
video description below so check that
out as some of you guys may or may not
know salmon are a strange fish they're
born in fresh water and when they're
just about like an inch long they do
this migration all the way out to the
salt water they spend most of their
lives out in the ocean get nice and fat
and when it comes time for them to spawn
they head back to the rivers where they
were born they go up there they spawn
they lay their eggs and they drop dead
so if you want to catch salmon in the
fresh water you have to do it during the
run when they're spawning and you only
have a couple week window to catch the
salmon however out in the ocean
you can catch them as long as you can
find them and here in the winter time
there are some kings that stay
relatively close to shore that you can
target in the dead of winter and so it's
one of the few fishing opportunities
here in alaska in the middle of
wintertime other than ice fishing
so welcome to catch a mech bay
oh look there's someone surf fishing
that dude's my hero right there
[Music]
okay here we go
roller coaster ride
how you doing babe
so far so good
we've got babysitters so we've already
won
[Music]
you're good man
yes yeah you do it i do it great
well we had about six foot waves out
there and that's a little bit too much
to pull crab pots into fishing so we uh
we turned around and head up into
catchmack bay to find some calmer water
and it looks like uh it looks like we
might just find that
well this is pretty nice i don't feel
like i'm in an episode of deadliest
catch here
but how deep do you troll for the kings
typically it's like 45 dollars
oh that's deep
got some trolling hearing pre-rigged up
you got a big flasher right there it
kind of tracks the fish you hook your
rig up to this cannon ball and that
takes it down to the depth you want when
you hit a fish
it frees itself from this thing and then
you don't have to pull this big lead up
when you're fighting the fish
you can see the rod's bent way over
because it's attached to that cannonball
when a fish hits it's going to pop up
and then start doing this number
the
well this is a lot nicer in this cove
i feel like we're fishing rather than
trying to survive yeah
several song filled hours later with the
weather being so nasty we just couldn't
go to the fishing spots we wanted to so
we had to kind of try some
long shots and it just didn't pan out
but uh we're gonna pull it up and head
back to head back to the harbor but uh
apparently in the mouth of the bay they
had eight and a half foot waves
according to the buoy so
i think it's really good we stayed back
here in the back part
[Music]
well we survived it we made it back to
the harbor huh it is icy
you know it's cold when the salt water
is freezing
well i gotta say josh was a good sport
he called and warned us that the weather
was pretty awful and we wanted to come
we had our babysitters lined up anyways
he was not wrong about the weather
we've got to come back and give this
another go i want to get some crabs and
a winter king
all right guys it's another day we're
back in the car and we're headed to
homer to go try winter kings again you
guys ready yeah
hopefully we'll catch some crabs too
who's gonna catch the biggest crab i am
i am
well we made it to homer alaska but
we're here a little early because we
wanted to visit some friends we're going
to be visiting the cultures and uh we're
gonna do a little play date with the
kids
all right we're here at the kilcher
homestead with ivan's house
and uh it is an ice rink here
let's get you to safety first and then
we'll worry about it
yeah it's wood stove
yeah that actually works really good it
works really good that's what my grandpa
used
all right guys we're here with ivan and
eve kilter and if you guys watch the
discovery channel show alaska the last
frontier you might recognize them but uh
they also have a pretty strong social
media game on instagram and facebook i
think itself we'll put links in the
video description below to that who just
kind of hang out and let the kids have a
little play date here and for all you
people at home who whose kids wish they
were in our family all of my kids wish
they were in their family so
the grass is always greener it's always
greener
yeah you guys know
that is a hardcore tree house right
there
you got three kids and a cat on your
roof
oh this is this is your
oh my crosswalk i think it has recoil
there we go
oh
[Music]
all right we made it
there's a nice hill
we had a great time hanging out with the
kilters that was a lot of fun but we're
here at the landsat hotel and it's kind
of late so we're gonna get these kids to
bed and i'll see you guys in the morning
good morning
good morning everybody
oh
everyone who's excited to go fishing
raise your hand
hey two out of three ain't bad
good morning morning
all right guys we're gonna give it a try
we're gonna see if we can't catch some
crab and king salmon and the weather
looks a lot better than last time we
were here who thinks they're gonna catch
the biggest king salmon
how big is the crab you're going to
catch
you think like that big
got a crab pod that's been soaking for a
little while we're going to pull it up
and check it
put it through the pulley
and then you wrap it around there
and that pulls it up
boil it on up watch out you're in the
fight yeah how far down is it uh it is
about 390 here 390 feet deep
yeah so if you're wondering why you
don't pull these by hand
here's your answer here we
go oh
my goodness
look
at that
holy mackerel
look at that
there are so many in here this one's a
female so that one's going that was the
fuel yeah because it's got the round
bottom on the you can tell the males
here got the little v on them oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
oh look at that wow
these might be too small
look at all
dummies yeah i know i said what do you
guys think of that
yeah they picked those salmon carcasses
please nice one
look at that
is that crazy oh he's trying to [ __ ]
so if you find a female you can throw it
out and almost back
so this right here is a dungeness crab
and you're not allowed to keep these but
this is a really nice one here
you want to just chuck them over yeah
sure
and this right here
is a tanner crab
are these the same thing as snow crab
uh yes snow crab are either tanners or
uh oh paleo crab okay gotcha so most
likely if you get them in a store
they're appealing oh god there's just
more of those around
the tanners are also known as paradigm
crap look at that that is a beautiful
crab
nice male look at the size of that guy
okay another dungeness
three dungeness i've put over
now he's undersized so we'll add a
female so we'll let him go
okay
i don't do this oh yeah sure enough
there we go here you go bud
hey rebecca
here just don't let him get your face
right overboard
yeah
one
[Music]
yeah about 30 keepers we threw over
about a 15 or so undersized ones and
then we had about 12 dungeness in there
so that was
that was a nice one
very far
look at that chum slick coming up oh
yeah
well now that we have completely limited
out on crab let's go get some salmon huh
we're off to a great start here hey
tommy what did you call the crabs with
one claw one pinch
man at me bro that excellent anime
reference there tom canner crabs in
alaska require a harvest ticket which
requires you to fill out a survey about
the fish you catch or the crabs you
catch so we just caught our crabs so now
we got to fill out our paperwork
all right guys we're getting ready to
start fishing and uh we can catch a
whole bunch of different things but uh
this spot we're kind of hoping for some
rock fish but we can pick up some salmon
and
i mean lots of things can happen it's
the ocean
i just got another hit
oh there's a hit there's a nice one
yeah sure
here
hold
he's taking some drag date you might
have a you have a serious fish
oh he got off he got off we could see
the hook but we'll get another one we've
already had two on in like a few seconds
there we go
there he is that's good oh oh
oh
look at that kelp grilling right yep yep
look pretty fishy
fish of the day
look it's a kelp grilling you can eat
them but they're not generally a popular
fish to eat so we're gonna put them back
got a few hits but we're not seeing the
signals and action that we're hoping for
so we're gonna go ahead and troll for
some salmon and keep an eye out on the
fish finder for big schools of rock fish
if we see something we can stop and
switch back to jigging so these are the
jigs we were using for rock fish but for
the salmon
troll bait is a little trolling herring
thread it on with a little treble hook
and they have a flasher with a literal
flasher inside
david
there you go
here i can see him
oh yeah there he goes there we go
oh
that's a good one yeah it's a king
salmon high five dog
high five nade
you knocked that one out nice good yeah
look at all the sea lice on
what
it's a little bug that sucks their blood
well there we go we're off to a roaring
start trolled for about five minutes and
boom boom got a double it's about an
average sized king salmon this one's a
still small
i'm not sure what jacob's up to but he's
under the table here
oh we got one we got one real real real
fast real fast don't yeah keep on
bending that rod
you keep off you give off
sorry buddy
how you feeling babe
a little a little off
it's not great
i love you my brave supportive wife
we got a few rockfish signals here we
might try drop it down for some rock
fish
oh i think i got one already
yeah look at that another beautiful kelp
really what a pretty fish
by the way those make excellent bait for
lean cod
nice black bass a delicious fish i love
eating these guys
we got quite the smorgasbord going on
i have to let it go
oh it's on
yeah
little kelp grilling bring it over here
pretty thing yeah
oh yeah
not a halibut but a flounder
felt like a good one
look how pretty that is
we got another one
look at that
well guys we had some luck with the
kings we had some luck with some rock
fish but the waves are getting a little
bit nasty and and becca's feeling a
little seasick so we're gonna go up into
the bay a little more sheltered spot
let's see if we can't do some fishing
there and get back on some fish
well i got a bit of a cold wind kicking
up so it's kind of nice to be trolling
and just hanging out in the cabin a
little bit get out of the wind i want to
see if we can get becca a king salmon
here the fish gets on just shove your
children out of the way don't don't even
hesitate let's throw nathan to the side
all right mom
go get her
go get it
yeah don't worry right one right right
right
oh it's moving he's stripping that's a
nice one there we go
oh it it's it's yeah you can take it out
oh
yes best fish of the day
good job man
what do you think babe was that fun
that's great
it's cold all right we got three kings
in the boat this is not bad at all
well we had a great trip and a good time
but the weather's getting crappy on us
so we're going to take those salmon and
crabs and rock fish back to the harbor
and clean them up we'll take them home
we're going to show you how to cook them
it's gonna be awesome
oh that is a pile of seafood right there
look at that and this is a big mama
hi
hey hey no attacking jacob with the crab
the saw the deadly crustacean
this crab is a white king he's got the
white meat instead of pink meat
yeah look at that that that is white
meat yeah this is the comparison that's
that's what they're normally like this
one's got white wheat on them and
sometimes you even get them when they're
like kind of marbled and stuff probably
one every ten fish or something there we
go that is a lot of seafood
we are loaded you can just kind of break
it over the side like this
split right in half and then you kind of
got
a little
gunk in there and then the lungs are
down there
fingers off and you're good to go
daddy
daddy this one's me
all right well thank you very much that
was such a good time
if you want to come here to homer and do
this too check out big butt charters
i'll put a link down in the video
description below and uh definitely
check that out if you're in the area oh
yeah
hey thank you
do you guys have a good time yeah yeah
well time to drive four hours back to
acreage and uh cook up some crabs and
salmon
all right guys we're back at the house
and it's time to cook up some crabs and
salmon we've got a whole bunch of family
coming over so this is going to be
pretty awesome all right like you know
if it you can
they want the magic groups or when
people eat you know they
they ask
you know at the same time i'm not liking
that
but
it was like
it was uh
they're trying to
tell you about
they have any questions
[Music]
speaking of creatures
[Music]
well there we go that is a pile of crab
legs let's get him in the hot water
[Music]
all right guys here we go nothing fancy
when you got good ingredients you don't
need the complex recipes we got fresh
alaskan salmon because this is a white
salmon it's kind of a funky color but
they taste just as delicious big pile of
snow crabs that's only half of it the
other half are still boiling over there
and some fruit and salad and rice peel
off yes i like skinny skin
and there's some garlic butter on the
table and there's more of the brown
sugar sauce right there if you want okay
they're right there on your peel off
how do we do this have you ever taken
aikido or any sort of jujitsu
just kind of do an arm bar and then
break the elbow yeah pull it backwards
pull it out and see that's the tend to
want to try to get as much of that as
you can
yay
no no more crab bites no more bites do
you like the crab yeah you guys like it
was the crab good yeah
there you go guys a lovely delicious
mess hopefully you enjoyed watching this
as much as we enjoyed eating it if you
guys want to see more videos from the
outdoor boys youtube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every saturday morning thanks for
watching guys
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching